okay one other similar story about new
reporting that we have
earlier this week i told you about the
forthcoming book
i alone can fix it by washington post
reporters
carol leonig and philip rucker and
during the week there have been little
leaks about what is in that book
there is now a new york magazine report
with more information about what's in it
and also some cnn reports and what is in
this book
is absolutely and totally wild
let's first look at some cnn published
quotes from the book
starting with donald trump talking about
the german chancellor angela merkel you
know joe biden today
is meeting with angela merkel and we'll
be doing a press conference with her my
sense is that
biden's perspective on merkel is
different than trump's uh
donald trump reportedly said in the oval
office
quote that [ __ ] merkel as well as
i know the effing krauts
and i was raised by the biggest crowd
of them all kraut of course a pejorative
for german people trump reportedly
referring to the chancellor
as that [ __ ] merkel also reported in
this book
uh general mark milley was worried about
how do we protect the inauguration
and milly uh reportedly uh uh
said quote here's the deal guys these
guys are nazis
they're boogaloo boys they're proud boys
these are the same people we fought in
world war
ii and then lastly from cnn's reporting
on quotes
from the book i alone can fix it nancy
pelosi
uh reportedly saying of trump after
january 6th
this guy's crazy he's dangerous
he's a maniac we have deep concerns
the new york magazine report outlining
that mark milley said trump preached
quote
the gospel of the fuhrer referring to
adolf hitler
general mark milley the chairman of the
joint chiefs of staff
likened donald trump's effort to hold on
to power after the 2020 election to
adolf hitler
saying the president was preaching the
gospel of the fuhrer
with his lies about the election being
stolen according to
the book i alone can fix it by carol
leonig and philip rucker
the pentagon's top general said shortly
before the january sixth insurrection
that trump had led the country to the
brink of its own
reichstag moment viewing him as a
potential threat to the american
democracy
it seems very clear that mark milley uh
uh
you know what you actually know what's
really funny about this
was it last week or the week before that
we had that clip of mark milley
saying during a hearing hey guys listen
um
just because you learn about critical
race theory
doesn't mean you become some kind of
cartoon woke
character in the same way that mark
milly said
we are a university at the military and
we want to learn about marxism we want
to learn about communism we want to
learn about critical race theory we want
to understand
what are the beliefs of people within
the country and outside of it it's
it's quite clear you know whatever you
want to think about mark milley
that the fact that he's a student of
history has served him quite well
in being able to look at the hit at the
past
and find situations that are analogous
to what we saw under donald trump
um the article points out trump had
appointed millie to be chairman of the
joint chiefs in 2018
over the objection of defense secretary
james mattis
the army general's tenure at the top of
the pentagon at the top of the pentagon
had been relatively quiet until last
summer
when he appeared in uniform during an
infamous photo op for trump in lafayette
square
that followed the clearing of protesters
in front of the white house
millie apologized for creating a
perception of the military involved
in domestic politics although the book
chronicles millie's concerns with trump
dating back to that moment
the general's worries grew rapidly as
trump plunged the nation into chaos
following election day
seven days later millie got a call from
quote an old friend
with an explicit warning that trump and
his allies were trying to overturn the
government
millie was confident that any attempts
by trump to hold on to power would be
thwarted
because the military wouldn't go along
they may try but they're not going to
effing succeed he told aides
you can't do this without the military
you can't do this without the cia and
fbi
we're the guys with the guns still
millie was disturbed by the sight of
trump supporters rallying to his cause
in november
calling them brown shirts in the streets
leonigan rucker wrote that millie
believed trump was stoking unrest
possibly in hopes of an excuse
to invoke the insurrection act and call
out the military
even at that high level there was the
fear
that that's what donald trump wanted to
do a key difference between
trump's dictatorial delusions and those
of adolf hitler
trump is in his mid-70s hitler was in
his 40s when the reichstag burned
trump could still get a good run if he
were re-elected in 24 right but
it is a different situation in that
sense significant
significantly different age i actually
am looking forward to this book i alone
can fix it
normally i'm not big on these books but
this one i do plan to read one of our
sponsors today is magic spoon the
delicious breakfast cereal that tastes
just like those cereals i loved as a kid
but
with zero grams of sugar only four net
carbs
and packed with 13 grams of protein
magic spoon has been advertising with us
for a really long time and it's only
because
our audience loves magic spoon so much
and people keep buying it
that's how you know that it's good magic
spoon
is great if you are doing low carb or
keto
it's perfect if you just want to eat
less sugar like me
it comes in flavors like cocoa fruity
frosted peanut butter blueberry and
cinnamon
you can build your own variety pack and
try them all
the whole david pakman show team loves
magic spoon the blueberry one is one i'm
i'm liking that one recently
it's crunchy it's delicious it's sweet
but not loaded with sugar and carbs
go to magicspoon.com pacman the link is
underneath this video
and you'll save five dollars when you
use the promo code
pacman at checkout